joining me today is the host of the
relatable podcast a speaker a
commentator and a cat person
Allie Stuckey welcome to the report
thank you for having me all right
Stuckey I have wanted you in the studio
for quite I'm so glad to be here it is
good to have you here but we got I got
two bones to pick just have to do with
cats number one person what's going on
yes she says sweet I love dogs I have a
dog she's a rescue I have two cats cats
are just they're cool and they're easy
they don't need that much of your time
that much of your attention I travel a
lot like you do and so it's nice to just
be able to leave the cat's but you got
to put a dog in a kennel you got to pay
a bunch of money they need your time
they need your attention they need to go
outside cats are cool they don't really
want to hang out with they are plotting
to kill you most of the day you're
looking at you that they could lunge at
you at any moment no that's a stereotype
that I would expect someone on the left
to make but it's not true you have to
take cats by their individual
personalities and not categorize them
look at how you just used identity
politics against majors great right it
applies to the animal kingdom too I just
needed you to know all right
that's number one I'm just gonna have to
agree to disagree on cats and dogs
number two for about two years I had the
number one Praeger you video why I left
the left sorry then you came in there
you took number one away from me but
actually I don't know if you know this
as of don't ask did you see somebody
else took I don't even so we need to get
them in here now we have a bone to pick
with them yeah I actually can't remember
who was or what even the topic was I'm
sorry this morning I was like I don't
even want to know I don't even want to
know but you you was what was the title
of it it was masculinity I think it was
like make men masculine there's
something like that so I guess that was
a hot topic that people really wanted to
hear that I mean it was so fun to make
obviously you've made prettier you video
too but I didn't really anticipate it
being one of those viral videos I kind
of just thought okay most people in
general agree with me but the vitriol of
course that I got you just you're
continually surprised
by some people on the Left who are so
opposed to what are very traditional
ideas so yeah alright well we're going
to talk about some of those traditional
ideas we'll toss talk about masculinity
and me too and a whole bunch of other
stuff called for people that don't know
you yeah where did you come from what's
going on here yes so I started in this
whole kind of political I won't even say
media fields but kind of about three and
a half years ago so fall of 2015 I was
working in PR I graduated from college
in 2014 PR social media just had kind of
your normal agency job but in fall of
2015 I lived in a college town Athens
Georgia and I looked around and the
friends that I had both in college and
out of college had no idea what was
going on in the election it was the
primaries and I thought these are really
smart people and a lot of them are
conservative in their values and yet
they seem to be touting these
progressive views when it comes to
politics and they really have no idea
what's going on and so I really just
kind of had a random idea when I was
driving one day called my mom and I said
you know I think I want to tell sorority
girls why they should vote in the
primaries because they seem so apathetic
I feel like I can talk to this crowd
because I was a story girl about a year
before that and so I created this it
really was a nonpartisan presentation
for for college students for why they
should vote in the primaries and I
started reaching out to add the sorority
presidents and you can find that
information online I just said can I
please come I want to speak for free
it's gonna be nonpartisan I just want to
tell you guys why you should vote in the
primaries and it works I mean I started
speaking to some of these groups and
then I started getting it asked by other
organizations on and off campus to come
speak and then from that I started a
blog and that was called the
conservative millennial ditch the
nonpartisan thing pretty quickly and
then after a few months of doing that I
started making videos and that's kind of
when it took off so and of 2016
beginning of 2017 is when it probably
officially became a career started
working at the blaze and then that
changed to I moved to see our TV that's
where I started my podcast and that was
the beginning of 2018 yes I'm getting my
ears confused beginning of 2018 that I
started
Podcast so still speak still commentate
I still write still do a lot of the same
things I was doing three and a half
years ago it's just involved into a
full-time thing yeah
pretty sweet when you start doing
something and next thing you know it's
because they become something right not
bad wow do you come from a political
family or anything did you care about
politics before this or was that just
your wake up when you realize nobody
knows what they're talking about at
college I would say both and mostly
mostly the second one I I grew up in I
wouldn't say it was an a political home
I knew we were conservatives and I knew
we liked that the earliest president
that I really remember his George W Bush
and I was really young during 9/11 and I
remember the patriotism that my parents
showed and that we were supposed to show
I knew we were supporting george w bush
and we kind of grew up watching fox news
but politics it wasn't a discussion that
we had at the dinner table necessarily i
just knew the values that we had my
parents were entrepreneurs they came
from very poor families in arkansas they
had no money when they got married they
were 19 and 20 and they really went from
nothing and then built a business and
built a life for my brothers and for me
that was so much better than the ones
that they had and so the idea of freedom
of entrepreneurship of not having a cap
on your potential was just always really
attractive to me so there was never a
time in college high school even as a
rebellious teenager that I was like you
know more government control actually
sounds really good it just it just never
never occurred to me that that would
lead to a better life I just always
loved the entrepreneurial spirit and the
idea of the American Dream that my
parents embodied so it was more of those
values rather than talking about
politics my dad did become a state
representative when I was in college I
think it was 2012 and so yeah that
probably spurred some interest I started
probably getting more knowledgeable and
more informed about actually what was
going on but yeah I would say it's more
a lifelong value building thing and then
by the time I graduated college I was
like oh my gosh I feel like our nation
is kind of at a crisis how does religion
play a role in that
I play the huge it plays a huge role you
know we hear a lot especially from
people on the left that
your religious view should have have no
impact on what you believe politically
well that's just a false idea of
religion and a false idea of your faith
if your faith is the center of your life
what religious people believe that it
should be and it's going to affect
everything it's going to affect all of
your values it's going to affect
probably how you vote and it's going to
affect that the things that you believe
in politically and the way that you
think that the country should go and so
being not only a born-again Christian
but also a Protestant Christian having
roots in even the Protestant Reformation
and how that kind of affected the the
movement of the West towards freedom and
towards individual liberty I think has
certainly been a legacy that was passed
down to me and it all just it all has
always made sense I wish I had like a
better journey story of changing my mind
but the idea of individual liberty and
human dignity and all of the rights that
come with that it just it just always
made sense the stories that come from a
little more of an evolution that they
involve more violence and pain and anger
a good story yeah they make for a good
book yeah
perhaps meaning so when you got into the
online world and started posting videos
podcasting and all that were you shocked
it's sort of the tenor and the way
people talk about these things and all
that well you know when I first started
when I first started the blog and then I
started doing videos I mean one I had no
money no backers no idea what I was
doing and I mean the first videos that I
did are in my living room I have no
makeup on no light I'm using my phone
look ridiculous got no views whatsoever
and so it was after I persisted for a
little bit sometimes I look back and I'm
like why did you even persist no one was
telling you to but you did and then it's
really the first time that you get any
kind of attention or affirmation that
you also see the other side of it that
you also see the negativity when you're
just doing it kind of for yourself and
for the few people that follow you
you're like this is great everyone loves
me but three people that follow me all
love me my parents and my husband love
what I do this is great but then as soon
as something kind of blows up yeah
as they say you see the negative side of
it and you realize okay people don't
just disagree with you they really hate
you and they really think that you're a
bad person especially if you espouse any
kind of faith that immediately comes
into question if you disagree with them
and that was hard I mean I used to focus
on the comments a lot you have to stop
doing that though it's so unhealthy so
that's kind of that's changed over the
past few years definitely but yeah I
think the hatred threw me for a loop at
first yeah well it just sort of comes
and you don't really know what to do and
then at some point I think I've come
around to the place where it's like the
more I get I'm like oh I must be doing
something right yeah because people used
to lie about what I was saying and I
didn't like that now they actually quote
me and I'm like oh wow this is actually
great this mud must be feel like when
you made it I think it was actually you
that tweeted the other day some article
by right-wing watch was IU and yeah they
they did an article on me not that long
ago - they quoted something that I said
@cr TV and of course everything looks
like it's some hit piece but then I read
it I'm like that's what I what I said it
was the one of the first ones I was like
this is an actual basically an honest
piece great they were really quite what
did you exactly and I'm like if people
think that's crazy I'm totally fine with
that yeah but like you said don't lie
about don't worry about what I'm saying
yeah is it unique to be a woman in this
space use a little identity politics
here I thought Republicans and the right
I thought they hate women yeah listen to
women don't they subjugate women yes I
just like being subjugated but I am
wearing shoes and so I am I've against
that part of it no I I've never I've
never really understood that argument I
guess if you equate women's rights to
abortion and to this mythical gender
wage gap that needs to somehow be filled
by the government if you equate women's
rights to that and women's empowerment
to that then sure I guess the left is
the only place for women but if you
believe in entrepreneurship if you
believe in the marketplace if you
believe that women have the potential
and the dignity that a man has and the
potential to do everything that a man
does in a way at least as far as her
career goes and leadership goes then I
don't see why you wouldn't be a
conservative unfortunately we do have a
PR problem
on the right and I'd voted for President
Trump but president Trump doesn't really
help the rights case when it comes to
women not just because it thinks he said
and done with women but also I think a
lot of moms especially hear him talk
hear him at his rallies he's got a
little bit of a of a mouth and they're
like I don't you know I don't really
want my kids listening to that that's
not who I want my kids to be I wouldn't
marry someone like that and so I do
think that he makes it a little bit
difficult sometimes to make the case is
that the odd catch-22 of almost
everything Trump does because we talked
about this briefly right before sorry
where it's like the policies pretty much
make sense and if you can remove that
from the tweets or the person it's like
he's actually at a ton of high level
women totally in the administration if
you carry that's what you're looking at
yeah it just makes it more difficult I
think that you're able to do it but when
the left has such a monopoly on media
megaphones when they have a monopoly on
Hollywood they have a monopoly on
academia I won't say monopoly but
they're controlling a lot of the
messaging that comes out and they're
they're good at PR they're good at the
emotionalism that not to be sexist but
appeals to a lot of women and so you
hear the rhetoric of Trump is putting
kids in cages and he grabs women by the
genitals and you're a woman you're like
I can't vote for that I can't do that
and so in order to separate some of the
lies from the truth and separate the
things that Trump has said from the good
things that he's done for men and women
you have to think and you have to go
step further you have to do your own
research and a lot of people male or
female just don't want to do that when
you can read headlines by just swiping
your thumb why are you gonna take the
time to actually click on an article and
then double check it and make sure that
it's right it's just harder to be a
conservative for that very reason takes
more effort how do you cut through the
clutter I mean that's one of the things
that especially when I go to college is
that kids ask me all the time like how
do you actually figure out what's true
yeah who's reading all of these articles
it's like I mean we know because they
write them about us and then it's like
well I know what lies that we're in
there so what else what else are they
lying to us about oh you really have to
try to go to the source if you can if
they said that someone says something
you have to actually go to the actual
quote or the actual video I mean a
perfect example of this is when
President
just the other day the the clip of him
saying are allegedly saying that asylum
seekers were animals was circulating
from British yeah it was deceptively
edited and so in order for you someone
like Chrissy Teigan who tweeted about it
and said that you know he's awful okay
in order for you not to believe chrissy
teigen in order for you to not believe
the tweet that she quote tweeted here in
several democratic candidates by the way
yes also so it's not just hollywood
celebrities even though they no he
wasn't
just to be very clear here he was not
saying that animals he was specifically
talking about ms-13 which is a totally
appropriate description of them but in
order to realize that that's a lie you
have to jump through a lot of Hoops I
mean because say I'm someone on the left
or say I'm someone in the middle and I
see Dave Rubin or Ben Shapiro
say that's not really what he said well
why should I believe you anymore so you
have to go to the actual source you have
to go to actual reporting it's more
effort that's something that you and I
are probably willing to do because we
know the game that they're playing but a
lot of people just don't know but I also
think that's why people are turning away
in especially young people from
mainstream media and from talking heads
and listening to podcasts where there's
conversations and when there's dialogue
where there's nuance and where people
are willing to say you know I don't know
that much about this here's what both
sides are saying I hardly ever see that
on the news so I think I think that's
part of it it's a change in the media
landscape yeah where do you think Trump
fits in I try not to do that much about
Trump in general but since you brought
him up yeah where do you think he fits
in with sort of the future of
conservatism then yes I can sense a
little push and pull with you on him
yeah I mean I voted for him and I think
I'll vote for him again it's mostly
because I voted for him in 2016 mostly
because lesser of two evils then I
didn't think that he was going to lead
very conservatively I mean especially
pro-life is a huge issue for me he had
just a few years earlier said he was
pro-choice he didn't seem to emulate any
of the conservative or Christian values
that I hold in my life but then I looked
at Hillary Clinton and I looked at how I
felt like the country was torn apart by
Barack Obama over the past eight years
and I was like okay someone who is going
to probably advocate for legislation and
surround himself with people that
more with my values or someone who I
think is diametrically opposed policy
wise to everything I believe so I chose
him and I think I would choose him again
because again I not that I would ever
vote Democrat and I've never been on the
left but if I were say I were a centrist
I would be looking over to the left in
saying okay this guy don't like what he
says don't like his personality I think
he's too brash and sometimes he doesn't
make any sense he calls Tim Cook Tim
Apple okay yeah like he's a little
embarrassing but then I look at people
who are advocating friendly term
abortion open borders and socialism and
I'm like I like my babies in my private
property I think I'm gonna stick with
Trump and so yeah I'm even more so in
that camp because I am a conservative
and I do care about the future of the
country and I hate socialism so of
course I'm gonna vote for him again and
I think that's how a lot of people feel
so sometimes a hard case to make yeah
that's how I see it I mean it's like if
you guys could just not be that bananas
then the refugees wouldn't do any even
you but you guys can't not be completely
insane no well sometimes I wonder if
it's a strategy are they taking us to
the nth degree are they taking us to the
the most crazy Marxism that they can
actually take us are they taking us -
for example medicare-for-all
just so we'll get on board with health
care for all are they taking us to open
borders just so we'll be okay with
abolishing ice are they taking us to you
know killing babies outside of the womb
to where we can say okay as long as it's
limit to the second trimester because I
mean I don't think that's going to work
but I do wonder are you guys pushing us
to the limits so we'll settle for
something a little bit less but that's
still liberal I don't know yeah I mean I
suppose I suppose that could well you
know I don't know what the answer is but
I suppose they could be do I mean Trump
does a little of that right you stake
out something really far and then you
come in I mean that's what negotiations
are about yes I don't know but watching
these guys go off the deep end has been
quite something and I so I mentioned to
you a couple days ago on on Twitter so I
you've been hitting aoc pretty hard and
I think your arguments you never attack
her personally you always go for policy
or for the the context of what she's
talking about yeah tell me a little bit
about why you're not thrilled with aoc
well we hear a lot of people in the life
saying
AOC gets to y'all she's really getting
into y'all and she really bothers you
and I'm like yes she really does I'm not
even gonna pretend like she doesn't
especially bother me
she specially bothers me because she is
representative of Millennials which she
isn't really but she's representative of
the stereotypes of Millennials and she's
a woman and so she is claiming to
represent all Millennials in all women
and she is espousing and saying
everything that is so diametrically
opposed not only to what I believe in
but what is good for America and also
like she just says dumb things just dumb
it's not that ok she's crazy like I
think Bernie Sanders is crazy but I
think he's probably smart like he can
make a pretty good argument she just
isn't good she's not even good at
fulfilling her own arguments and I think
it's her
it's the hypocrisy to of saying well no
one has any legitimate concerns with me
no one has any legitimate criticism I'm
going to pull this random tweet from
this person with ten followers and say
well this is all of the right making fun
of my shoes this is all they've got well
no there's been a lot of people asking
you for dialogue and debate and to
discuss ideas and policies and you
refuse to that's what bothers me
yeah so what do we do about that because
the the energy of the media the focus so
much of it is on her I agree I don't
think she's particularly bright I think
she has handlers that at times yeah are
writing her look she's not writing most
of these tweets yes maybe she types them
out but it's very clear if you listen to
her speak the way she speaks and her
understanding of information is very
loose and then in in Twitter form she
knows all these things about history and
policy and all of these things and the
idea that she wrote the Green Deal or
any of that stuff now it's just all
nonsense but what do you do if so much
of the energy is focused there which I
you know I think we're in agreement it's
dangerous yeah how do you move that if
she won't debate yeah I think that all
you can do is advocate for your own
policies an idea is the best way that
you can and yes of course to call out
her lies and say this is why it's a lie
I mean you might not convince everyone
but maybe there is one person who
thought that her tweet was awesome
looked at what you said and said okay
well maybe now I am starting to see a
pattern of not just her but people like
her that use eye
politics and use this victimhood
narrative someone like Ilhan O'Mara's
well to say oh you can't criticize me
I'm seeing that a lot maybe her
credibility comes into question so I do
think that's important I think it's
important to keep it above for it as
much as we can with the criticisms now
I'm not necessarily good at that like
sometimes I just want to all fails oh
yeah and I don't I don't want to call I
mean I don't think I ever go for
anything super personal or ad hominem
but there are times where I just want to
be like this girl's an idiot she's an
idiot girl
and I don't think that's that's probably
just to call myself out I don't think
that's the most productive thing to do
we should probably say why she's wrong
but someone who I think is actually
trying to play her same game it's a
little bit different because he's older
and he's a man but Dan Crenshaw is using
social media to his benefit to actually
talk about what's going on in Congress
say here's the legislation I'm trying to
get past here's what the Democrats are
doing here's the back-and-forth fight we
have hardly any transparency in Congress
from the right we don't have a young
representative that's saying okay this
is what you're hearing here's what's
actually happening AOC is trying to do
that but you do have someone like Dan
Crenshaw who is trying to do it on our
side and I think that's important what
do you think is the goal of this new
crop of Democrats like do you like to me
they genuinely want to change every
fundamental law and every fundamental
philosophy that has underpinned this
country for over 200 years and yeah
really
it sounds alarmist it sounds
conspiratorial but I think they're
deeply unpro
and it's very sad for me as we talked
about right before we started it's like
this ain't the party of JFK anymore
right it was one thing when we just
disagreed on policy it's another thing
when we disagree on patriotism it's when
we disagree that fundamentally America
was founded on good ideas maybe you
don't like the founder founding fathers
maybe you don't even like that they own
slaves
maybe you think that America has a bad
history we can probably agree on that
that America doesn't have a perfect
history but us not agreeing on basic
constitutional values of individual
liberty of the rates that are endowed to
us by our Creator that creates a whole
other host of problems we have not more
complicated disagreements between this
new crop but more fundamental
disagreements more simple disagreements
we've ever had before that's what makes
them so frustrated and people like me
like us who care about American values
and are down with the Constitution it's
really kind of mind-boggling like we
don't even know where to take their
arguments sometimes but when you look at
what's coming out of the academia I mean
all this postmodern garbage it kind of
makes sense I mean they've been taught
that America is this imperialist
aggressor and everywhere boots have been
on American boots have been on the
ground evil has spread and white
nationalism has spread that's what
they're learning you're like okay I can
see where they got that it's sad because
it's inaccurate but I think that's kind
of where it's coming from and that's
what they're promulgating yeah are there
parts of the right that you're not happy
with definitely I mean if the alt-right
is even still a thing I feel like it's
kind of had its heyday I literally pray
that it's had of course I don't like
them I think they're a bunch of internet
trolls they're people also who think
that the world the West is going to be
won back through memes I don't think
there's anything wrong with me another
all of me don't know that was anything
wrong with that but I don't think that's
primarily where the with where the
battle is spot and then I do get
frustrated with people who can't ever
criticize Trump when he says things for
example and this was a while ago saying
okay we'll take away their guns and then
due process or something like that or
where they can't refute him on trade
they can't push back at him at all or
they try to paint him into like this
almost demigod savior that bothers me
because okay let's not pretend that he's
Ronald Reagan he might have even done
better things than Ronald Reagan in a
lot of ways but let's not pretend that
who he is as a man is Ronald Reagan that
he represents all of our conservative
values I think it's okay to say you know
what as a Christian I don't really agree
with a lot of the things that he says a
lot of the things that he's done
I still like his policies but I'm just
gonna be honest I don't love everything
that he's done the people that will not
say that that bothers me I just don't
get it do you think that there's like
sort of a sickness around the cult of
personality related to our politicians
the way we talk about them and think
about them I mean so you could take that
with Trump from certain people you know
the certain just diehard Magga people
who would never find fault
and you could take that with the
obsession with oh there
with his shirt rolled up standing on a
table and skateboarding and just the way
we talk about them like they're all
celebrities or that that they have the
wherewithal yeah fix all our problems it
all actually feels gross to me like
politics feels very gross to me for
someone that talks about it as much as I
do
yeah I don't know if it's because it's
gotten so dramatized that it almost
feels like our favorite soap opera you
know how someone has a character they
just love and can do no wrong they're
like I'm fighting for this person in
this show it's almost that are our
politics have become so celebra ties
which really almost started with Barack
Obama and so dramatized that people have
picked their favorite characters and
they feel like they have to pick one and
there's there's no way yeah there's no
way that they're gonna pick the other
one but I also think it has to do with
the fact that they see their enemy as so
bad as so crazy as so radical and the
left is beating up on Trump so much and
so unfairly that they they I think
they're honestly thinking and maybe with
good intentions why would I pile on that
sure maybe I don't like some of the
stuff that he does but we never hear any
of the good that he does so I'm gonna be
a part of the group that talks about the
good that he does and not the bad so
maybe maybe those intentions are pure
yeah so I I do agree with that I think
that there's a certain set of people
that think well wait a minute this guy
is relentlessly getting attacked and
lied about less reinvestigations and
everything else so when he says
something like to me the one that you
hit on will take away the guns first and
then the due process to me that probably
is the worst thing that he has said in
in the two-plus years and I could see
why a decent person that would know that
that's wrong wouldn't go crazy about it
because a he probably was probably just
like sloppy language maybe right yeah
maybe but be it's like everyone's
attacking the guy constantly like cut
him some slack there's a danger of that
too
yeah and I think it's that they look at
his actions they keep saying or I should
say we we look at his actions like do I
think that he is ideologically pro-life
do I think he really cares about
abortion probably not now maybe he's
been awakened to like a lot of people
have with the New York law and the
Virginia bill that didn't get passed and
said okay that's really bad but I don't
really
care what he personally thinks about
abortion because he's been a pro-life
advocate and I think that's a good thing
and I want him to advocate for the
things that I believe in and I always
knew and I was always pretty confident
in the fact that even if he's not an
ideologue which I think we all knew that
he wasn't he was going to surround
himself by people that would push the
values and the policies that
conservatives
believe in and that's nowadays that's
really all I care abouts almost all I
wouldn't say all but that's most of what
I care about not to get my vote so is
that the irony I guess for Christian
conservatives is that you needed a guy
that was gonna do play a dirty game and
and maybe you couldn't get Romney or
McCain yeah they tried it the other way
like those guys weren't gonna play in
such a way because it's not just that
you're fighting the candidate you're
also finding a media establishment in
the colleges and all that that's not how
I thought of it because I didn't vote
for him in the primaries and like him in
the primaries I actively talked about
not voting for him in the primaries what
do you make of what's the the onslaught
against Christians because I talk about
it I talk about it pretty frequently on
Twitter and here and I'm not Christian
but I see what's going on and this is
now the state sanctioned bigotry yeah
that's okay not quite state but like
yeah if you care about what the media is
oh you know I always attack white
Christian men they're all homophobes and
they're all bigots and all of this
nonsense yeah and I go to events with
these people all the time and I find
them to be decent and respectful and
willing to disagree and and walk away
without punching yeah yeah everything
else but what do you make of just like
the focus yeah on that well it's part of
it's part of intersectionality you
posted the quiz the other day that it
was like what's your intersectionality
score your sexuality school yes it one
of the things that you could slide was
whether or not you're a devout Christian
the more devout of a Christian you are I
guess the more privileged do you are the
lower you are in the intersectionality
scale or something like that and so I
think it's just associated because
America and the West was driven by by
Christianity and was driven specifically
by Protestants I mean the Revolutionary
War was seen as a Presbyterian rebellion
and a lot of those people aligned
anything with omit anything that is
aligned
Americanism is white nationalist is
wrong is imperialist Christianity gets
tied up in that now for evangelical
Christians we also know because the
Bible tells us that the Church of Christ
is going to be pushed to the margins
until the world comes to an end and so
we will be persecuted we will be more
and more marginalized and yes we can
continue to fight for Christian values
we continue to fight for being left
alone really is what we're really
fighting for just kind of leave us alone
that's what Protestants pretty much have
always done but yeah I mean at the end
of the day we know that it's not going
to end well for us probably yeah it's
really crappy situation like everyday
just another tweet and another story
this nonsense you know they'll do Chris
Pratt's Church and they'll try to make
me seem like oh he's a homophobe but he
goes to this homophobic Church and it's
like guys you want to do a lot of Omar's
mosque now you want to do that but they
don't want to do that yes actually
they're the bigots right that really is
the truth yeah and that's the thing is
that they're fine
they're really fine the left is fine
with you being a Christian as long as
you don't actually believe what the
Bible says so as long as you believe the
stuff about feeding the poor as long as
you believe that kind of stuff but that
has to mean the government's right is
longer you're down with that but you
have to take away the wrath of God you
have to take away Jesus being the only
way truth in life you have to take away
the biblical marriage stuff you have to
take away the abortion stuff if to take
away the hard work that proverbs talks
about that even the Apostle Paul talks
about gotta take all that away as long
as you're the Christian that believes in
wealth redistribution you're good yeah
all right so let's dive into some of the
topics of the day you mentioned the the
wage gap yeah it was recently it was
what was it gender pay gap day you don't
even I don't even know I just made sure
to pay all my female employees less that
day oh really drive it home yeah is it a
myth
what's going on here it's a myth because
well it's partly a myth what they don't
tell you is the entire story is this
whole uncontrolled gap through our
versus the controlled gap but I actually
heard about this
originally on a more left-leaning site
that's an organization up in Seattle
that fights for equal pay and they
actually taught me on their site the
difference between an uncontrolled gap
at a controlled gap the uncontrolled a
great Twitter threat on this by the way
which will link to in the description
yeah yeah it was a controlled gap
account or I'll start with the
uncontrolled gap does not account for a
job title doesn't account for experience
as an account for hours work
it really doesn't put any factors and
it's just the median what women make
versus the median what men make which is
79 cents to a dollar that is true but it
doesn't account for any choices or an
experience the controls gap accounts for
all of those things so it accounts for a
job title hours worked all of that it
doesn't account for like negotiating
arrays doesn't account for end of your
bonuses or anything like that but it
does account for the big factors and
that is 99 cents on the dollar so women
make 99 cents to every dollar that a man
makes but again you're not accounting
for a few factors there and that could
be within the margin of error so no
matter what there is no proof that there
is systemic sexism that is causing women
to make less money well it also doesn't
account for the fact that men and women
choose different careers at the most
simple level I mean the best example of
this is sweetums have been you know
completely a gala terian for ever
basically I guess what there's still
more male engineers and there's still
more female nurses yeah so now they want
to like force people to do things that
they don't actually want to do so they
can get it 50/50 which yeah that's
really all freedom works no and there's
an I mean there's a million different
programs to try to get women into stem
because they've said for so long that
the reason why there are so many more
men in stem is because women feel
intimidated them because there's this
patriarchal attitude in the stem field
while so they've tried so hard they've
put so much money behind it and still I
mean men are outpacing women or there
are so many more men in stem that I mean
just as many as there's ever been and so
it's probably not any outside factor
it's probably because women in general
are different how much of this do you
think is just misguided sort of
confusion so for example you're pregnant
now your husband's here in the green
room
your careers are gonna be a little bit
different you're gonna probably take
some time off to child rear yeah maybe
he will take some Praetorian time maybe
not but that but just physiologically we
just are different they don't like
talking about that yeah but that is just
the nature of reality I saw a study the
other day that was like breaking news
and it was some study out of the UK that
showed that there is a difference
between boys and girls brains inside the
womb that is as early as you know
however many weeks gestation that a
child's brain is developing and they
start going in these divergent paths of
women that just how the neurons connect
and women kind of being grown into these
interpersonal creatures whereas men are
more focused in general on objects and
data and things women are more focused
on ideas and words and people that
starts in the womb and I'm like I'm so
glad science is finally catching up to
God and finally catching up to the
things that we've known for thousands of
years and so you do wonder if that's
going to happen if okay we're trying all
of these cool social experiments right
now like maybe oh maybe it'll be fine if
we draft women like maybe it'll be fine
if we just pretend we just are totally
gender neutral with our kids and pretend
like no binary definition of gender
exists but I do wonder if science will
catch up with us and be like actually
all these things that conservatives were
saying that the left thought were social
constructs they're just biological
reality well they also might find out
what if they found out that there was a
gay gene one day yeah now they're
pro-choice would you you have to be okay
then with a woman deciding to abort that
baby because because they don't want the
child to be gay and that does put them
in this kind of ethical conundrum I mean
but it's the same thing with with race I
mean I guess you would know what race
your child is obviously before you have
an ultrasound or anything like that but
you have I mean there is a racial aspect
to abortion and that the majority of
abortions happen in minority communities
and so when you ask a pro-choice er
about that they don't typically have any
kind of answer though all right wage gap
you briefly mentioned the trans
situation or gender roles yeah the trans
issue for considering its you know
zero-one yes and the population or
saying and I have complete sympathy yeah
with the issues that they're dealing
with little overblown in our national
discussion yes and I think that the left
does that a lot maybe I'm gonna give
them the benefit of the doubt maybe with
good intentions because people with
gender dysphoria it truly is a struggle
I know someone with gender dysphoria and
it is a struggle they didn't want this
they didn't they don't like this kind of
struggle of feeling like they don't
belong in their own body it really is a
psychological struggle but you treat it
as a struggle you treat it as something
that okay we don't just say well live
what you want to live because they
actually the rates of suicide are pretty
much equal afterwards
it doesn't actually reconcile anything
when we say okay just do what you want
to do because it truly is a disorder in
a dysphoria and I think maybe in an
attempt to be compassionate to the
people that are dealing with this and to
help them not feel ashamed the left has
said you know what we are just going to
validate who you are I personally don't
think that's the compassionate thing to
do to lie to someone and I know a lot of
conservatives feel the same way but then
you do start finding yourself getting
angry and defensive about a subject that
we should have a lot of sympathy for it
because people force you to use gender
pronouns that you don't want to use they
force you to have conversations that you
don't want to have and that's where
things just get really sticky and that's
when unfortunately conservatives
including me we get really dogmatic
about it and the sympathy and compassion
is thrown out the window yeah so what do
you do to fight that because that I get
that it's tough if you just keep being
called trans Fobo or any of these folks
well eventually you're just like all
right then enough of this I'm gonna go
for the destroys tweets out of the
compassion tweet well the tweets are
difficult because the tweets it's like
you only have so many characters and
putting out the nuanced compassionate
tweet is typically not what comes to
mind I think when you're just trying to
put your put your idea out there you
don't have time to add the nuance here
like I'm just gonna get to the point I'm
not saying that's right but that's
typically my tendency and our tendency
and I don't think that's a good thing
but in conversations I always think it's
really important to define your terms if
you have a same leftist who is saying
you're a trans folk okay well we need to
define phobia and we need to define what
I believe in what you believe and maybe
we actually agree on a lot of the same
things we just disagree on the facts we
just disagree on the variables so I
think defining the terms is important
starting with what you agree is
important and then working out from
there how often do we do that
maybe not often so what would you do you
think it's fair to say that the average
conservative well first off you know the
when they keep putting phobe at the end
of fo biz in irrational fear so I assume
you don't think that the average
conservative has an irrational fear of
trans people no I don't think so okay so
what what do you think the average do
you think the average conservative has
the thoughts that you laid out earlier
which is sort of a sympathy for this but
then we don't want that to override yeah
are thinking brains okay I think some
people are saying you know what I really
don't care if you dress like a girl or
you dressed like a guy or you'll want to
call yourself something I just don't
want you to force that on me I don't
want you to take away for example my
religious liberty in lieu of like I I
don't know they don't want their rights
trampled upon in favor of this small
group however I do think there are
people that kind of see where this line
of reasoning goes that if okay we deny
biological realities we deny what
science is telling us and we buy into
this delusion that a man can just wake
up one day and say that he is a woman
then okay we kind of lose we kind of
lose all truth what is truth anymore
it's just what you feel we lose identity
it's just who you say you are or are you
actually defined it maybe way by biology
and I think they see the kind of
slippery slope that goes down and they
say okay stop right there I'm not down
with this and it all sounds crazy to
just wake up and you know middle-aged
and be like well now female but it's
like what at that point I mean this is
this sounds bananas but if you were a
washed-up male NBA player who couldn't
play in the league anymore you can be
like yeah I'm a woman today I identify
as woman right yeah I'm jumping in the
WNBA and I'm gonna be the MVP watch this
and then the feminists would have to say
yes lives experience yeah well that's
the other problem with it is that you're
kind of seeing some feminists push back
on this and say hang on well old-school
feminists have been kind of saying okay
we fought for the uniqueness of women
the empowerment of women because women
our women and now men are beating us at
our own game men are better at being
women than women are that's not fair and
so I do think you see feminists pushing
back on that who truly do believe that
okay the reason why we fought for the
empowerment of women is because women
are unique only women can have children
only women can do certain things women
are better at some things the men are as
far as leadership goes as far as
organization goes things like that and
they fought to bring those things to the
forefront and now none of those things
matter anymore because you can be a man
to be a woman so there is just I'm just
so glad I'm not on the left it just
seems so confusing it's like all right
so you're preggers you video make men
masculine again why did they have a man
do that why did they have what was the
idea we're gonna have a woman yes talk
about male masculinity I think it's
because you're seeing a lot of women
talk about how terrible toxic
masculinity is and say ah men they just
they don't even know how hard it is and
they've oppressed us for so long we just
need them to take a back seat and so we
can kind of step up and do our thing and
so I think they wanted the perspective
of a woman to say hang on just a second
women actually do not only do we like
masculine men or not even necessarily
traditional masculinity I'm not talking
about like writing a four-wheeler I'm
talking about taking responsibility for
your actions and taking care of your
family taking care of that provision and
protection that men are so good at and I
think better at than women are so you
could still wear a nice shirt let's say
yes you should be able to take care of
it yeah it's more internal traits than
anything else and the actions and the
habits that you have the
responsibilities that you take women do
care about that and actually the
complementarian relationship that men
and women have had for ever has has
worked really well it's worked really
well not always I mean sometimes it goes
over to a patriarchy and that's not good
I don't think oppression of women is
good but the the yin and the yang the
back and forth and the complementarian
relationship that we've had has worked
and I think you kind of needed to hear a
woman say that so why do you think the
left's trying to destroy that because
they think a Galit arianism will equal
equality so it's equality through
homogeny which is part of why abortion
is a really big thing
they fight for if a man can physically
walk away from an unwanted pregnancy a
woman should be able to - I mean a
pregnancy the ability to get pregnant is
really one not one of the only things
but probably the biggest thing that
makes a woman different and so if we get
rid of that through abortion and then
maybe men and women really well be the
same and maybe they really will be equal
then there'll be no abuse no oppression
no patriarchy things like that but I
mean men are always going to be
physically stronger than women and
there's always going to be bad men and
bad women so oppression won't stop abuse
won't stop egalitarianism is just going
to make or not shouldn't say
egalitarianism but sameness is going to
make things more confusing not better so
I know you do public speaking too and
when you go to colleges do you find you
have any tricks on how to wake up say
some of the lefties that are you know at
least open to some of these ideas
they're kind of like she must be the bad
guy but I'll at least go and sit in the
bathroom well what I try to do is I try
to my messages typically when I come
usually speaking to mostly conservatives
is that okay you're hearing that you're
crazy for believing in things like
border security for being pro-life for
being Pro capitalism but here's where
these ideas come from and here's how
they have worked and really only over
the past 10 to 15 years have we heard
all of this crazy intersectionality
identity politics stuff that they are
acting like is mainstream and so you're
not the extremists you're not the
radical you're not the one that's out
there you're not the Nazi and the bigot
you believe things that Americans have
believed since our founding and they
have a really good history and a really
good basis and so I don't know if that
has necessarily ever changed the leftist
mind but it is something that's
different than just talking points and
saying the left is stupid it's saying
hey we have good ideas and you have a
right to believe they're good ideas and
you have a right to defend these good
ideas really the the most disrespectful
or the craziest I always get very
respectful great liberal students that
come and listen and ask awesome
questions I think the only time that has
been like oh my gosh I can't even get a
word out without these people screaming
is when I was at UC Berkeley and ice
Seiler dumbass yes and I spoke to a
class and the professor was awesome for
asking me and I actually thought when I
went in there I was like I meant I have
a really tame
I got a really tame with what I say I'm
not gonna say I'm not gonna throw any
flames or anything like that oh my gosh
I couldn't even it was like they had
never heard a conservative idea they had
never heard someone who wasn't a liberal
utter a word and it was irrational it
was irrational
that was really my only experience when
I was like this is crazy
they've abandoned thought you and a
weird way blame the baby boomers for
this because it's their kids right like
or it's the end of their the young end
of their children like so anyway you
can't blame the the 16 year old who now
gets into college you know a couple
years go by
he's been indoctrinated in high school
gets to college gets slammed with more
of the stuff I have sympathy for him
well when they're yelling at me I don't
have that much sympathy for ya but like
I have sympathy for that condition
because they were just thrown into that
yeah
we're not that you're looking to blame
somebody but if you had to sort of
figure out where this whole thing
started yeah where would you go well the
baby boomers
really like to talk about how terrible
Millennials are and I agree with them to
some degree I mean a lot of the
stereotypes that people have of us stare
entitled in apathetic are true but I
remind them like we were raised like we
were raised by someone we weren't raised
by wolves and I don't think it's so much
that parents probably told their kids to
be entitled or told their kids to be
spoiled I don't know if it was a lack of
values that were taught in the family
but also there was a significant change
from the time our parents were kids like
my mom for example was you know she was
driving to the liquor store to get her
dad beer when she was like 13 years old
I mean car seats like that just wasn't
even a thing I mean everything was a lot
more free to the time where we were kids
I remember there was like a new law that
said you have to be in a car seat until
you're like in second grade or something
like that everything changed everything
became more safe and everything shifted
from like the latchkey kids who were
coming home and finding for themselves
that's mostly Generation X because both
their parents had jobs to kind of these
helicopter parents and these everybody
gets a trophy or this everybody gets a
trophy mentality that we had and school
it's not like we didn't have competition
but it was that everyone gets some kind
of reward I would know I'm terrible at
running I'm so slow and yet in every
race I got I got honorable mention
honourable mention I got something and
that's how we were raised I swear to God
so I'm Gen X so I'm a little older than
you but I swear to God I remember being
in third or fourth grade field day and I
was I was a scrawny little kid I was not
a good athlete I became a good athlete
later and I remember getting a slip feel
bad not place I didn't get a medal and I
remember getting some sort of
participation thing and I'm not kidding
I remember as a third or fourth grader
thinking this is nonsense yeah like why
would you give me this I felt shitty I
felt bad I sucked it whatever we were
doing like a slow bike race another and
I sucked why did you get it right right
yeah we've we've sold this yes if this
is how it's supposed to be yeah I think
I mean it's parenting it's technology
its values its purpose it's so much I
mean you do also
you can't deny just the effect the
personal technology had on Millennials
and I mean we had iPhones from the time
that we were probably 15 we had
cellphones even before that we had
MySpace
xanga if anyone remembers that you had
faces I think it was before my eyes I
didn't have it but I remember some
people did you had AOL Instant Messenger
so you had personalized technology from
a really young age that told us that
everything is about you everything is
focused on you and then the older that
we got we got Netflix we got a breeze we
got all of these things that made life
really convenient instant gratification
always we don't know anything other than
Amazon I don't know how to read a map
like I don't I remember my dad trying to
teach me how to read a map in high
school I was like yeah dad okay a map is
how to refold it the rest it's like
whatever but yeah just fold it back in
the way it came out
well I don't even know how to do that so
and I think most Millennials don't it so
this instant gratification things should
be easy for me as they are in the
technological world has really affected
our politics too do you feel that the
technological part of this has actually
really screwed up a generation then like
that there's obviously a lot of goodness
and we're doing this on you too yeah
yeah that was that it really like we
will we hand it everybody it doesn't
matter what age you are we all got
handed this incredible technology to
open the world our heads but especially
if you're a 15 year old being handed
that yeah that's that's a lot to give a
kid yeah I want to hesitate to blame all
of all of it on technology I also see a
loss of values and that we're not only
the most progressive generation but
we're also the most irreligious
generation we're the biggest generation
of religious nuns in omes and I do think
a lot of us are wandering looking for
truth not really knowing what that is
not me but a lot of people in our
generation I don't know if that comes
with technology at all or if that's
connected but it's certainly a factor
and why I think Millennials just don't
have any Center they don't have any
grounding and they just think that their
centers themselves and we're told this
all the time on social media I mean your
favorite fitness blog or your favorite
self-help author is just love yourself
if you just look in the mirror in the
morning you tell yourself you're awesome
that you're enough then you're gonna be
fine and that's what you need to do
everything's about my happiness so you
cut out the toxic people in your life
you cut out the things that you don't
like the things that make you sad and
you just do you yeah you'll be pretty
lonely yeah I mean there's a drop it all
the way right and I mean what do you do
when the self love runs out what do you
do in the self esteem runs out what do
you do when you wake up in the morning
you're like okay I'm not that awesome
and I haven't accomplished that much
should you just continue to coddle
yourself or should you do something
about it and the millennial is told
coddle you'll be fine and then you have
someone like aoc saying well we're going
to provide economic security for people
who are unwilling to work and so if you
or just want to be a watercolor painter
even if you suck at it you should just
keep doing it yeah so there's a lot of
money in watercolor painting generally I
wouldn't know because I'm not good at it
but I can imagine gay marriage let's
talk about it from a Christian
perspective so when we're posting this
we're holding this video for a couple
days but I just had Sapiro in here and
yeah we've talked about gay marriage and
he talks about his feelings from an
Orthodox Jewish perspective and we can
we've basically gotten it to the place
where we agree to disagree
and what we agree to disagree on the on
the fact that he's not okay with it
through a religious perspective but he's
not trying to legislate my life and I as
a citizen of this country I'm completely
okay with that yes I suspect that's
probably similar to your it is similar
now as a Christian there is a little bit
of I would say a second layer to that so
he obviously believes that homosexuality
is wrong because the Old Testament says
it we believe it not just because the
Old Testament but it's reiterated in the
New Testament and then there is this
crazy picture in metaphor that is given
to us in Ephesians 5 that says okay
marriage is a reflection of what
Christians call Christ in the church as
Christ as the head of the church so the
husband is the head of the wife and so
it's this husbands are to love their
wives as Christ loved the church and
wives are supposed to submit to their
husbands as to the Lord so there's this
spiritual component this gospel
component to marriage being between a
man and a woman so there really is no
theological way for any Christian they
try but to get out of the dynamic that
God set up not just biologically and
physically but also spiritually and so
that's where I stand as far as a
religious perspective now I've heard
both sides of it I have heard
conservatives and even libertarians that
I respect saying you know what I just
can't get behind I just can't get behind
gay marriage from even a civics
perspective or from a legal perspective
you heard libertarians know that I've
heard Liberty I would say not anyone
famous I would say friends who probably
have libertarian views still say maybe
that was maybe they don't feel that way
anymore but just say it's so hard for me
to separate the personal from the
political but where I stand politically
is probably the same I would say
probably the same place as Ben dies I
mean one gay marriage is here to stay
there's nothing that's going to be done
about it and I don't think I are
probably any other evangelical in the
political world is going to fight
against it but I think what does that
tell you quickly about evangelicals in
general because I think this is
important I've said this many times but
it's like nobody cares about gay
marriage anymore really in the big
picture like I get your theological
yeah yeah personal belief but in the
public political
space yeah something that was anathema
to this group of people for a long time
now has become normalized pretty quickly
I think
I think by and large Christians have
realized that their communities aren't
getting worse that the neighbors next
door have kids and they're the same as
everybody else that you don't even hear
Mike Huckabee going on about it anymore
or Rick Santorum or any of these guys
they've sort of moved on and I think
this is where I would love the
progressives have a little humility yeah
like just a little bit of you know what
me maybe you guys were wrong right you
were wrong but then something happened
and you didn't you let it go yesica Lee
and that would show a little humanity
and humility and they just refused to do
that yeah and again this is where then I
can find myself building bridges with
you guys all the time because yeah
because there's a place to build the
bridge to yeah I think that a lot of
evangelical conservatives realized okay
yes America was founded on Christian
values and we should continue to
perpetuate those Christian values but
the state does not define marriage God
defines marriage and I think that
churches should be free to say sorry
we're not gonna we're not gonna marry
two men you know right and yeah and I
knew that you did and I think that we
kind of made that separation and say and
said okay God defines marriage in the
Bible if I don't want to get on board
with it because I am beholden to God and
God above the state then that's fine and
churches shouldn't be beholden to the
state in that regard either and I think
that we kind of decided okay
that's fine if they want to get married
according to the state's definition of
marriage that's okay but I and my
congregation are not going to change our
views on it and we just kind of want to
be left alone in that regard yeah so
what would you what do you make up when
when churches do perform gay marriages
like these yeah I'm just sort of
skirting their theological Yesi
integrity oh yeah I mean this is a huge
thing in the United Methodist Church is
that they've kind of almost had a split
because they voted on this so-called
traditional plan saying okay if you're a
Methodist Church if you're under the
United Methodist Church umbrella this
denomination you can't perform gay
marriage or you can't yeah you can't
perform you can't perform these
marriages and there were a lot of people
who are really a
said about that and but from a Christian
perspective you just can't get around
that there's no way to get there's no
way theologically to get around it
without making some serious not just
physical concessions but spiritual
concessions and so my question for
anyone and it's not just about gay
marriage it's about anything in the
Bible my question is if you don't take
the Bible as God tells us to take it why
are you a Christian
find a different hobby like theirs you
can you know you can be a moral person
you can yeah you can be a good person
and you can believe in feeding the poor
without following Christ but Christ
tells us to deny ourselves take up our
cross and follow him and part of that is
adhering to the word even when it's
inconvenient and not culturally cool so
I'm just a little bit confused by those
theological concessions but yes to
answer your question I do think that
it's compromising on what the Bible says
yeah what do you think that would
actually in practice what does that mean
you know you mean like so in practice
gay people start getting married now
doesn't matter outside of the church
what do you think the practice of that
would lead to in society that would be
all right okay outside of the church
yeah outside of the church do you see
that some sort of problem well I I of
course do you think that God's way is
better than man's way and I do believe
that God setting up marriage as a union
between a man and a woman is better I
think that it's better for I think it's
better for the family I think it's
better for children and I think because
it's better for the family it's better
for society now do I think it's going to
be the degradation of society do I think
that we're our whole thing is going to
hell in a handbasket because of that no
I don't but of course I think that the
way God set up marriage and family in
the Bible is better than how secular
society does it and yeah so that's where
I feel that I feel like we are and feel
like we'll probably be going
however homosexuality is it different or
necessarily worse than other senses
different kind of sin because it's a
sexual sin according to Christianity but
it's not worse we don't believe that it
puts us in a worse place than all of the
other sense that America has done what's
so funny I know what's gonna happen now
so people are gonna clip this and
they're they're gonna go out see there's
Ruben
with another homophobe yeah to his face
sitting in his house where he lived yeah
you like hanging with homophobe right
and it's just like I mean I said it to
Ben so I'll say it to you like as long
as you're not trying to legislate my
life I yeah and maybe there's a part of
me that I'm like maybe I should care
more should I be more offended or
something like that
yeah I just don't well I think part of
it too is one you want to be left alone
like so many people like Christians do
to like go live your life yeah you want
to be left alone and I think also and
you can correct me if I'm wrong but a
lot of the problem that especially
Christians see on the left is that they
conflate sexuality with identity and so
if I disagree with your relationship
from a Christian perspective then that
must mean that I hate you but I don't
hate you I think that you're a great
person I think you're a smart person and
your husband's awesome and so they a lot
of people on the Left seem to not be
able to separate those two things that I
can love you as a person and respect you
and admire you as a person and not agree
from my own Christian perspective with
your relationship now I also think it's
important to say though it's not if I
were to what Christians would say
witness to you if I were to share the
gospel with you it would not be hey Dave
you're gay and that's wrong that would
not be the message what we believe that
unbelievers people who are not
Christians are repenting from when they
come to Christ is unbelief it is not
your primarily your primary sin is that
you're gay or that you are a thief or
that you're anything else it's that you
don't believe in Christ and so that's
what we believe that we are preaching
the gospel to unbelievers to be saved
not gay people to make them straight now
we do believe that through
sanctification that we all have to
repent from our sins but I think it's
important also to distinguish that that
what we're talking about salvation
sharing the gospel with people it's not
necessarily saying our primary message
isn't that you're gay and that's bad
yeah but do you think people could just
stop being gay if they repented and
stepped well I know two different
stories there is a really good book by
someone who I totally disagree with
it's a ways but she wrote a good book
now she probably wouldn't say that Oh
God makes people straight but it's
called gay girl good God's by Jackie
Hill Perri and she did live life as a
gay person and then she kind of had an
awakening she came to God and she's
married and she has kids there are
stories like that but I also know
stories of people there is another
amazing story and I don't want to save
the title because I'm I don't wanna say
the title but there is another
incredible story of someone who became a
Christian he lived life as a gay person
he actually was in prison and he lived
life as a gay person and he became a
Christian and he lives as far as I know
he was a celibate lifestyle and so he is
not married he is probably never going
to be married he might not ever be
attracted to women but because he is a
Christian and Jesus has called us to
deny ourselves whatever our desires are
that are simple he loves a celibate
lifestyle and so I think that one just
strikes me as deeply sad like I can get
you know like really like you know I'm
pretty tall heard about this stuff
obviously that one just strikes me as he
is gay he there is this religious piece
of him in there that so the answer is
then live alone and don't have kids and
don't have a family yeah is where you
start completing sexuality with identity
and romantic relationships with the
ultimate fulfillment and that's not what
the Christian believes actually Paul
says for everyone it's better to be
single than to be married he says I wish
you were all like I was so you can be
fully dedicated to the Lord and we
believe that if you're straight or
straight or your same sex attracted then
the gift of celibacy is truly a gift
that you could dedicate all of your
passions to God so we don't see celibacy
as this sad awful lonely thing we
believe that in Christ you have full
fulfillment full satisfaction whether
you were attracted to the opposite sex
or the same sex and so I think he would
tell you great person had the line I'll
tell you his name but I would think he
would tell you that he finds a full
satisfaction and full joy in his
relationship with Christ now that does
not mean it's easy right well I was
gonna say he would also sort of have to
say that to rationalize his exist
that's right like me I don't know we
happy to have the conversation I'm not
sure that he would I don't think he
would have chosen because he was living
an actively gay lifestyle his name is
Christopher you want and I think he's
incredible I don't think he would have
chosen to be a Christian or I don't
think he would have become a Christian
if he didn't think that there was
something to it if he didn't think that
it was worth it I mean he's seen the two
alternatives and he chose one direction
so he obviously thinks that one is more
satisfying than the other I mean he got
nothing out of at least Anjali in this
life saying okay I'm gonna give that up
and become a Christian yeah so it makes
you wonder it does make you wonder it
should make you wonder about
Christianity what is it about Jesus that
would make someone give up what they
thought their identity was where the
world says well that's where love is is
just being yourself and loving who you
want to love